my name is kunda Dixit I'm the editor of
the Nepali Times newspaper in Kathmandu
and co-publisher at gmail media my job
is to direct and to supervise four or
five editors who work at the
english-language paper as well as look
at the overall business health of Hema
media which is a private media company
well I guess with me with all my known
ancestors being poets or writers there
was just too much ink in the blood so it
was inevitable that I'd end up being a
writer although I had sort of a bit of a
sidetracked into science and doing a
course in biology and geology in the way
back but I sort of drifted back into
journalism
despite that that bypass on my career
well before I got into journalism I did
my first master's in in science
microbiology and my thesis was on biogas
technology and alternate energy systems
for rural third world so how do you make
methane gas for cooking from cow dung
for example and my special interest was
on how to make this work in a cold
climate like in high-altitude Nepal in
the Himalayas it works very well in the
plains where the temperature is 30 to 35
degrees Celsius but it doesn't work as
well in cold climates so so I did some
research into that started writing about
it and slowly drifted into writing on
environmental issues then as I got
deeper into writing on environment I
found that there are links to
development
directly linked to to environment and
development is directly linked to
politics so it was with a sort of very
logical course that writing on
environment took me directly into
mainstream media and so my first job was
to work for an english-language
newspaper in Katmandu
but my side job was to string for
Reuters news agency I wrote articles for
time and life at that time working with
Elizabeth Hawley in Katmandu did a lot
of mountaineering reporting because in
those days 90% of the news that was
exported from Nepal was about
mountaineering who climbed what mountain
and who died on which mountain so that
is how I drifted from science into
mainstream journalism the Panos
Institute was based at that time in
London and they had offices in Africa
Latin America and and also Asia I helped
set up the South Asian Bureau and office
of Panos Pano's basically dealt with
training people in communications on
specific fields like thematic areas like
trans boundary water or environment or
gender or hiv/aids or TB stories with
the soft focus which the mainstream
media was not really that interested in
so how do you bring the expertise among
journalists in this thematic areas up to
speed so that what they write is
credible and and written with with
expertise so we worked on that for about
two years and panelist was a it's a very
good place to work with a whole lot of
journalists in India and Nepal Pakistan
Bangladesh Sri Lanka where the problems
are very similar and where journalists
could actually learn from each other a
lot and of course water being one of the
thematic areas we worked on was also
linked rivers don't respect man-made
boundaries they flow across borders and
cross countries
and and we needed to look at watersheds
and an entire environment from a more
trans boundary perspective and and on
with panels we did we had fellowships so
that Bangladesh India and Nepal
journalists could work together for
example on the Ganges basin and we took
them on field trips down from the
Chinese border through Nepal through
India right down to the Ganges and
Brahmaputra Delta so then they got a
perspective that all water is different
you know water you really have to look
at it as a regional natural resource I
think unfortunately the the media in
Nepal and around the world actually
don't really understand the the science
of energy and also the politics of
energy it's reported as just as another
beat and usually it's the economic or
business beat but energy has very very
close relationship with the environment
with natural resource allocation with
equity within countries and of course
has major impact on the global
environment and the atmosphere as we see
now with climate change what we've been
doing in Nepal since the late 70s 80s is
now coming out to be the accepted truth
for the way the world should go which is
renewables are using hydropower using
wind solar biomass very few people know
for example that Nepal is is a world
leader in biogas it's got the highest
number of per capita household by gas
plants in the world now more than
250,000 household plants which means you
know a farmer with five or six cows will
use the cow dung to put it inside a
digester which is usually underground
and and use the methane that's generated
to cook now this has absolutely huge
implications for the health of the
family because now the farmer is no
longer using firewood which was emitting
indoor smoke and therefore getting the
people sick who lived inside
mainly the children it had major
implications on conserving forests
because as you used biogas you didn't
need to go into the forest and got cut
firewood and it brought down the entire
energy bill of the country because the
whole country had to import less
petroleum gas for cooking in the same
way solar energy
I think a great thing about Nepal is
that at the time when you need solar the
most which is winter for heating water
or generating electricity the weather is
fine there are no clouds and it's
brilliantly clear so it's it's really
ideally that climate and everything is
ideal for solar wind has not been
explored that much in Nepal but there's
tremendous potential along many of the
north-south valleys which actually
become funnels for the pressure balance
between the Tibetan Plateau and the
Indian Plains mmm and and hydropower now
unfortunately with hydropower Nepal has
not really made progress and the reason
for that is manifold as lack of good
governance corruption the conflict
setback many of the hydropower projects
but I think we're now at the threshold
if we get the politics right to major
make a major leap in in hydropower and
not just for energy for electricity
generation but also for irrigation and
for regulating water because Nepal is
this has this problem of shortage and
plenty you know there's all the
rainfalls in three months most of it and
you really have to store that water in
order to use it
judicially judiciously throughout the
year you have to prevent floods and then
you have to have the water in the dry
season but luckily the Himalayas the
mountains are made in such a way that
the water is stored as snow and ice up
in the mountains and it melts in the dry
season and keeps the water flowing and
this is which is why the mountains are
regarded as gods and goddesses and have
names like Annapurna which means giver
Grainne because it's so important that
the melting of that ice in in March
April May is so important for
agriculture that we just have to make
sure that that water is stored is used
well and the challenge now of course is
that with global warming and climate
change the permafrost of those ice
towers in the mountains is is melting
and irreversibly so that's going to have
a major impact when Nepal was called a
yam between two stones and the joke
during the conflict in fact the leader
of the Maoists chairman / Chanda
actually said that it was a dynamite
between two boulders by which he meant
that Nepal is so geostrategic that
instability in Nepal would be a major
concern to China and India and it's true
I think but not in the way he meant it I
think both India and China their policy
towards Nepal actually converge
whereas elsewhere in let's say the
Indian Ocean or around the world India
and China may be rivals for for
resources and for for strategic reasons
but in Nepal their their interests
converge and I think both want stability
in Nepal there are one Nepal to be so
politically volatile that it affects
their internal politics and and India
for example would need stability in
order to cooperate with Nepal on sharing
of the river waters and and building
joint projects so India's main concern
in Nepal is water and and it's linked
directly to bilateral relation relations
between Kathmandu and Delhi with China
they need stability so that a volatile
Nepal will not be a springboard for
Tibetan nationalism and and China's
China looks at Nepal almost solely
through Tibetan prism and since Tibet is
such an important sensitive issue for
China they don't want the power to be a
problem
and as long as India understands and
accepts the annexation of Tibet which it
does China doesn't see India as a
problem visa vie Tibet I think to look
at the conflict in Nepal 1996 to 2006
you really have to go back to well you
have to go back right to our feudal
history but I think up to 1990 when we
had our first People Power
demonstrations on the street the
pro-democracy movement forced the king
at that time to allow political parties
to function and we had our first
multi-party elections in 1991 those
tremendous euphoria of democracy because
remember Nepal had been a absolute
monarchy a dictatorship for 30 years
from 1960 to 1990 and so from 1990 we
felt that wow we have democracy now
democracynow.org
very quickly and by 1995 there was a lot
of disillusionment among Nepal ease that
democracy was not really providing
prosperity and equity and all the other
things that we expected it would and and
one group of communists who are inspired
by Mao Zedong in neighboring China felt
that shortcut to to power would be
through a violent struggle against the
state and at that time it was against
the monarchy a constitutional monarchy
so they started their the revolution in
the mountains of Midwestern Nepal
following a lot of mouths teachings of
the strategy of revolution learning a
lot from Peru and the Sendero Luminoso
and how they conducted their revolution
and the the the objective conditions in
Nepal with feudalism
equity's lack of social justice was so
pervasive that the the revolution spread
like a wildfire I think beyond the
imagination of Maori that the Maoist did
not realize it was spread so quickly so
it was very easy for them to recruit
because if you talked about
discrimination and and injustice people
who you know wholeheartedly just just
joined the movement and of course the
the state's initial crackdown a very
brutal crackdown on the on the
revolutionaries didn't help because it
pushed ordinary people into the Maoist
fold so that's how it all started but I
think the Maoist would perhaps impatient
yes there was injustice yes there was a
lot of exclusion of marginalized
communities but democracy and especially
grassroots democracy in Nepal with the
decentralization and the self-governance
acts was starting to yield results for
the first time in Nepal local elections
for village councils and district
councils was directly leading to
accountable local leaders who were
forced to perform which means to provide
services like health education jobs
roads to the people if they wanted to be
elected again so it was starting to work
and then the war came at the same time
and I don't think it's a coincidence
that the first target of the Maoist
revolutionaries were precisely these
elected local leaders because they were
competing for the same constituency so
at by the end of the conflict in 2006
nearly 85% of all the village council
buildings had been destroyed and bombed
village council members were hounded out
of the of the villages many of them are
living in the district capitals or in
Kathmandu so something that was started
with a sort of a utopian dream of a
better Nepal basically ended up
brutalizing society setting back
development and I'm not saying that
there was no achieve
and I think it did it did make a lot of
people aware of their rights especially
the women marginalized groups but it
also let them down and as we have seen
in in the elections this week the the
disillusionment against the Maoist party
even within Maori scada has been very
very high so by 1995 media activists had
lobbied successfully with the government
to allow the radio spectrum which they
regarded as a commons to be taken away
from the state control and I think that
was a landmark thing radio sagarmatha
which was Nepal's first community radio
station was started in 1996 and that
opened the door for community radios to
come out and I think as far as community
radio is concerned an apology is right
ahead of all the countries in the region
I had even of India India with its you
know history of democracy and Free Press
actually controls radio with an iron
hand you are not allowed to broadcast
news even if you're a private radio
station all news is centralized from the
state radio whereas in a ballots there
are nearly 400 FM stations they're owned
by local village councils by NGOs by
community groups there are also
commercial stations but everyone is
forced to be act like a community radio
so I think this and this has
complemented democracy at the grassroots
I think the communication element to
democracy is given to Nepal and the
police through community radio because
they can't be democracy without
participation and for participation you
need communication and especially
communication at the grassroots meaning
decentralized media and I think this is
where Nepal is ahead of other countries
well in the beginning the Nepali media
treated the conflict and the start of
the revolution in these remote mountains
of Midwestern Nepal as if it was
happening on some other planet it was
treated like a ordinary law-and-order
story policemen killed here some attacks
there
it wasn't linked to a larger revolution
that was starting and igniting in the
mountains and Kathmandu couldn't have
been further away
reporters were lazy they didn't really
go out they didn't have the resources or
the energy or maybe the the interest to
go and report on what was happening
there and perhaps because of that when
the revolution spread rapidly and
district Capitol started being attacked
in let's say 2000 people in Kathmandu
were shocked the politicians Wow
this is serious business so I think the
media was part of the problem I think in
in making people aware that there was a
serious violent conflict starting in the
country and by the time policymakers
media and social society in Kathmandu
realize what was going on it was already
quite a serious war and I think as far
as for me personally the conflict and
reporting on the conflict I had been
writing and reporting on conflicts in
other parts of Asia I reported on the
Sri Lanka war at a time when there were
two civil wars going on at the same time
the Tamil separatist war in the north
and the Marxist revolution in the south
with the jvp I did Philippines the
aftermath of the Cambodian genocide and
so forth and coming back to Nepal I
really felt that you had to do
journalism differently if you if media
was going to be a part of the solution
in finding resolution to the conflict as
well as helping in the reconciliation
process
but somehow the rules of journalism
don't allow you to do that we are taught
at journalism schools to be spectators
not to be involved not to be outraged by
human rights violations for example and
you have to take that objective view of
what's happening little aloof that
doesn't work
I think if media is going to be a part
of the solution you really have to be
involved and I felt the limiting that
that the rules of journalism actually
limit you in getting closer to the truth
of what the conflict was doing
especially to civilians
so we tried in our newspaper and
magazine too to cover human rights
violations to do two more field
reporting to go out to the countryside
and find out how the conflict was
affecting civilians but even then there
was a feeling of inadequacy which is why
we started work on those on the on the
books on the conflict the war was coming
to its tenth anniversary it looked like
it was never going to end
and we really thought we could tell the
story of what the conflict had done to
us to Nepal ease and the country in
general through pictures through
photography I'm not a photographer
myself but I felt the power of
photography was very strong to tell the
story so we started putting together and
collecting photographs from Nepali
journalists foreign photo journalists
who had been to Nepal during the
conflict
even ordinary villagers were taking
pictures with with the very simple
cameras so and by the time the book came
out the war had ended and a lot of
people told us oh now now there's no
need for a photo book on the conflict
because you know we have peace but as
you know the end of the war did not mean
peace and the legacy of violence
continued and so the book was very
important not just as an exercise in
memory of the violence but also to try
to prevent such violence
again in future but the story told
through the medium of photography and so
the first book Larry magenta which means
people wore came out in in January 2007
it was an immediate bestseller and it
was just supposed to be one book but the
publisher decided not to make any money
from it
Nepal ayah and we said okay from the
proceeds of the sale of the book why
don't we take the pictures to the people
so we went on a traveling photo
exhibition around Nepal showed it in 45
of Nepal 75 districts by the end of it
half a million people had seen the
pictures and it's amazing it's not as
the quantity of people the number of
people who came to see but the intensity
of feeling with which they looked at the
photographs and saw themselves in it
their own war experiences and then they
all wrote very moving testimonies after
seeing the pictures in the guest books
and we were just so powerfully moved by
those testimonies that we said we must
chronicle this so the second book came
out called never again piteous the nos
which which select some of these
comments and puts it together you know
in a in a photo book with pictures of
the exhibition tour and the testimonies
next to it and then our friend casts on
set and who's Nepal's foremost
documentary filmmaker decided to make a
film based on the on the tour and and we
took that documentary called frames of
war you dodged etre also around the
country showing it in cinema halls in
about 15 districts and while we were
showing the film we would notice in the
audience people who you recognized as
characters from the first book so and we
talked to them and we'd hear dramatic
stories of what they had been through so
the instant at which that picture was
taken in the first book was actually a
very small part of what they had
actually experienced and we said we must
tell this story
so the third book came out which is
called
you'd the Pacis anta yeah people after
war which is a before-and-after kind of
story on on the characters from for the
first book including very dramatic story
which is the cover of third book which
is of a woman gorilla who was pictured
in the first book by sagar Shrestha is
this dramatic portrait of a woman
gorilla with a gun sitting in sentry
duty in Bhojpuri in eastern nepal
brilliantly composed photographed
technically perfect and we often
wondered what has become of our way she
now and we tracked her down to a
cantonment in in eastern nepal and we
found out that her name was actually jun
arai we didn't have her name in the in
the first book and her brother
Ruben Rai was in the army so brother and
sister were on opposing sides in the
conflict so Nepal's conflict was not
just a civil war but a sibling war and
the brother and sister could conceivably
have killed each other during battles so
this was very very powerful stuff and
you couldn't have made feature films or
documentaries or write novels about many
of these characters in the first book so
I think this whole project which grew
organically it wasn't planned like this
it was just supposed to be one book in
the beginning grew from a photo archive
of the conflict into almost a peace
movement and I think we were nudged
along pushed along by the people and the
desire for peace and justice and the
need to remember not to forget what the
war did to us you know I made a living
being a skeptic of new information
technologies the internet social
networking I said how is this going to
be a panacea how is this going to level
the playing field if our schools don't
have roof
on them how is sticking a computer into
a school which doesn't have teachers
which doesn't have electricity which
doesn't have textbooks going to help so
we are we are getting you know ahead of
ourselves that was my feeling and and I
think the digital divide within Nepal is
even more acute than it is globally
eighty percent of the internet sites
registered in Nepal are within the Ring
Road in Kathmandu so I was a skeptic and
then I think one day I had this moment
of Epiphany where through my smartphone
I could transmit a picture I had taken
off of a lake and mountains in a remote
part of northwestern about to the world
right from there two weeks walk from the
nearest road and yet telecommunications
had bridged that gap so the digital
divide obviously was getting was
shrinking and there was tremendous
potential for education and media and
communications with this technology and
so now I'm sort of somewhat of a
born-again and digerati you can see the
potential and and for media definitely
there is great value in magnifying your
audience as a reporter as an editor I
find directing people to come and read
what I write now it's possible through
social networking and to let people know
and discuss its dynamic content its
interactive it can be multimedia so just
this extends the the role of media a
mainstream media but of course
everything is changing it's not
journalists who are journalists now
there's also citizen journalism anyone
with a smartphone is now a journalist if
you're at the right place at the right
time
you can upload right from wherever you
are even in a country like Nepal and
things are changing exponentially we
don't realize how fast it is changing
one year ago I used to tell people at
seminars there are two million people in
Nepal with Facebook today I have to say
it
3.2 million 1.2 million people have been
added in one year with Facebook accounts
even in a country like Nepal it's going
up like that the internet penetration
rate is rising the people with mobile
phones is now sixty percent and as more
and more people get smartphones I think
the internet penetration rate is also
going to go up more people are going to
be accessing the net through their
smartphones than through their pcs or
laptops and the revolution that has
happened let's say in America Europe in
India even two or three years ago is
it's very rapidly coming to Nepal and we
really need so for media and journalists
to be trained in the technology they're
training at the moment is not adequate
people don't understand the role
Facebook is used mainly to be in touch
with friends the journalists are getting
into Twitter but there is media
education is lagging behind and media
education not just for journalists we
tend to think all media education is for
reporters to learn about social network
no it's for the public the public needs
to know how the media operates who owns
media how it is controlled for example
and and also the sensitivities of
smartphones and and new social
networking a lot of very a lot of young
men and women in Nepal as elsewhere in
the world have got into trouble because
they don't understand the medium and
issues like privacy and so forth so we
we really need to upgrade our school
curriculum both in high school as well
as college with media literacy even if
and those people are not don't want to
be journalists they need to know
I think with social media and new media
technologies at the moment we are in a
stage where the old media paper
newspapers are not yet dead and the new
media has been born but is still a
toddler so in this sort of transition
phase and the role of paper newspapers
will still be there but the eyeballs are
moving the readers have already moved
unfortunately the advertisers haven't
moved so you still need your hardcopy
newspaper as a vehicle of revenue for
for advertising because you can't really
charge yet in Nepal for your online
content so the online is still being
subsidized by the hardcopy but I think
this will change very rapidly it has
already changed for example in India and
and if it happens in India is gonna come
very rapidly to us is that the
advertisers will also shift the only
reason advertisers haven't gone yet is
because a lot of the advertisers are
older men like me who haven't really
realized they're still watching
television at home so they think that's
the medium but as Facebook users reach 4
million 5 million I think it's going to
happen already the advertising has gone
to Facebook in Nepal and it's only a
question of time before advertising also
shifts but Nepali times actually we were
way ahead of our time because when we
started the newspaper in 2000 we started
with an online edition for the first 4
months so we were online before we were
hardcopy so now I think we'll come a
full circle at some point and become
more of an online outlet than a hardcopy
outlet already there are three times
more readers of our online site then
there is all our hard copy subscribers